ad décidant par votre mouvement c'est
des accusations politiques qui n'ont
rien à voir avec les allégations portées
devant la justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé les les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont fermés est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi quand la guerre a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum interne à
sion pour laisser les sahraouis le choix
de choisir le futur de choisir entre
l'indépendance et l'intégration maroc à
savoir que ce n'est pas une partie du
territoire marocain
[Musique]
anthony blinken reçu à l'elysée le chef
de la diplomatie américaine s'est
entretenu avec emmanuel macron nouvelle
étape de sa tournée européenne
il a été accueilli ce matin par son
homologue français jean yves le drian
les deux hommes ont insisté sur
l'importance de la coopération franco
américaine face aux défis et crise qui
secoue le monde
[Musique]
les etats unis qui auront quitté l
afghanistan d'ici au 11 septembre
prochain le retrait des troupes
américaines est en cours
et c'est dans un contexte d'incertitude
que le président américain joe biden
reçoit à la maison blanche son homologue
afghan
ashraf ghani pour évoquer l'avenir de
son pays la maison blanche affiche sa
volonté de travailler étroitement avec
le gouvernement de kaboul pour que
l'afghanistan ne retombe pas contrôler -
et à gland
[Musique]
pas de sommet en vue chantre lieu et la
russie réunis à bruxelles les 27
dirigeants européens ne sont pas
parvenus à se mettre d'accord les pays
baltes la pologne la suède et les pays
bas ont bloqué une proposition
franco-allemande visant à relancer le
dialogue avec moscou
la diplomatie russe déplore l'union
européenne otage d'une minorité
agressive qui même le bas
[Musique]
eh bien
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france anthony blinken
reçu à l'elysée cet après-midi par
emmanuel macron le chef de la diplomatie
américaine poursuit sa tournée
européenne à à paris ce matin il s'est
entretenu avec son homologue jean yves
le drian une vieille connaissance qu'il
côtoie depuis 2012 lorsqu'il était
membre de l'équipe de conseillers en
politique étrangère et de sécurité de
barack obama
précisions de notre reporter katia
technique hier aux abords du palais
présidentiel après un voyage en
allemagne anthony blinken est venu en
ami en france
il a fait ses études à paris a obtenu
son bac il est francophone
après un rendez vous à l'eau c'est dès
ce matin il a rencontré son homologue
jean yves le drian qu'il connaît depuis
2012 et le ton des discussions étaient
enthousiastes amical les deux hommes
disent partager des valeurs communes la
démocratie la liberté le souhait de
faire advenir le multilatéralisme
jean yves le drian s'est plaint que la
france et l'europe on tue a essuyé des
attaques contre la démocratie et leur
valeur seules durant quatre ans qu'ils
ont dû tenir les murs durant les années
trump et anthony blinken a bien rappelé
que la france était un partenaire idéal
indispensable est encore plus important
à notre époque pour travailler de
concert et devenir plus fort sur cette
coopération bilatérale et multilatérale
je vous propose d'écouter jean yves le
drian depuis le début de l'année avec
anthony blinken nous sommes employés à
nourrir ce nouvel élan en remuant à
vianne up constant et confiant constant
et confiant qui est indispensable entre
nos deux pays est indispensable parce
que les défis immenses auxquels nous
sommes confrontés exige toute notre
énergie que soit la pandémie loge ans
climatique en passant par les inégalités
mondiales indispensable parce que nous
traversons un grave moment de
brutalisation de la vie internationale
c'est pourquoi l'approfondissement de
notre alliance est un impératif
stratégique que nous agissions at-il
bilatérales ou au sein de la relation
union européenne états unis
ou encore dans le cadre d'une otan
rééquilibrer où les européens se donnent
désormais des moyens de jouer pleinement
leur rôle
ce que le président mbaye d'année vous
même avez salué nous sommes plus forts
ensemble les défis de l'époque ont été
abordés l'urgence climatique la pandémie
la sécurité et la lutte contre le
terrorisme notamment au sahel
les américains continueront à aider les
français et ils vont soutenir également
les pays africains concernés
les deux hommes ont exprimé la volonté
d'aider le liban crise la difficulté de
revenir dans l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien et la nécessité de maintenir le
dialogue avec la russie
américains et français s'entendent
également sur l'attitude à tenir face à
la chine
vu comme un partenaire mais aussi comme
un concurrent est un rival et après un
dernier entretien cette fois avec
emmanuel macron anthony blinken prendra
le chemin de l'italie où il rencontrera
son homologue italien le président
italien sergio matar est là et au
vatican il a un rendez-vous avec le pape
et ce matin anthony blinken et jean yves
le drian d'évoquer le dossier de
l'afghanistan les troupes américaines
auront quitté le pays d'ici au 11
septembre
beaucoup redoutent le retour des
talibans le président afghan est à
washington pour évoquer l'avenir de son
pays il a été accueilli tout à l'heure
par nancy pelosi la présidente démocrate
de la chambre des représentants
il va être reçu par son homologue
américain joe biden analyste
géopolitique et bruno guigue revient sur
les enjeux de cette rencontre
je suppose qu'il attend une aide simuler
matérielles financières logistiques qui
pallie les inconvénients du départ des
troupes américaines puisque c'est avec
le pouvoir afghan depuis l'invasion de
ce pays par les forces américaines et
celles de leurs alliés dépend très
largement de l'aide fournie six états
unis différents pouvoirs qui se sont
succédé depuis longtemps donc ce qui est
important pour lui c'est qu'une période
de transition soit aménagé entre les
stations actuelles et la perspective
d'un départ définitif des troupes
américaines d autres d'ailleurs qui sont
encore dans ce pays donc c'est quelque
chose qui soit plus paraît un petit peu
dérisoire quoi en situation et
l'impression d'une situation sans issue
et le retrait des états unis de
l'organiste en inquiète particulièrement
les interprètes afghans qui ont
travaillé pour les forces militaires
américaines
plus d'une centaine d'entre eux se sont
rassemblés devant l'ambassade américaine
à kaboul
il demande à washington de les faire
sortir du pays qui en raison d'un risque
de représailles de la part des talibans
la semaine dernière des élus démocrates
et républicains ont déposé en ce sens à
la chambre américaine des représentants
un projet de loi qui vise à accélérer la
délivrance d'un visa spécial
d'immigration pour ses ressortissants
afghans en danger tout les troubles
étrangères se retirent complètement
d'afghanistan et après cela si nous
sommes pris pour cible par les talibans
si nous sommes tus et irresponsable de
nous c'est pourquoi nous demandons à
nouveau justice naze élevons à nouveau
la voix
nous demandons notre sécurité à notre
protection
les talibans ne sont pas dignes de
confiance ils mentent
d'un côté ils disent nous ne vous
dérangent roja mais nous n'allons jamais
vous déranger et de l'autre côté ils
vont continuer à nous tuer
donc nous ne pouvons pas faire confiance
un problème qui touche aussi les
auxiliaires de l'armée française dont
témoigne l'assassiner archilla il ya
quelques jours dans un second ancien
cuisinier sur une base militaire
française
comme d'autres face à la menace il avait
demandé à plusieurs reprises
rapatriement d'un déjà de la zac
il s'appelait abdul basir ils étaient
afghans et avait 34 ans ce père de cinq
enfants a été employé pendant cinq ans
comme cuisinier par l'armée française
durant son intervention en afghanistan
abdul basir a été retrouvé mort d'une
balle dans la tête le visage tuméfié
sous les traces de coups fait les
talibans seraient responsables de son
assassinat en formation notamment
diffusé par ce journaliste indépendant
qui a coécrit en 2019 une enquête sur
les auxiliaires afghans ce matin j'ai
appris l'assassinât par les talibans du
second pilier afghan de l'armée
française vie à son frère que j'ai pu
avoir au téléphone
bazire diane m'avait envoyé un mail en
est
et please help us la france avait rejeté
par trois fois sa demande de
rapatriement
d'après nos confrères du figaro abdul
basir réclamait depuis 2013 un visa
français pour sa famille et lui demande
rejetée
trois fois de suite par l'administration
française l'admistration française
heures avait choisi trois critères le
niveau de la menace la qualité services
rendus à l'armée française
et puis les rieurs de service l'armée
française donc pourtant le collègue
abdel basset al pouvez remplir ces
critères là mais malheureusement il n'a
pas pu bénéficier de la demande au roi
la cotisation au de cotisation en france
avec l'avènement de des insurgés et des
talibans donc les les interprètes ou les
auxiliaires des anciens aux élèves de la
remettre en question travaille avec la
france donc ils sont considérés comme
très très infidèle donc qui t'ont qui a
travaillé pour l'armée d'autant ils sont
considérés comme très fidèle il ya le
risque ou la menace de mort pour eux et
la menace de mort s'est vite concrétiser
l'avocat d'abdul bazire explique que la
justice ne l'a pas suffisamment prise au
sérieux je recevais régulièrement des
appels désespérés des mails intitulé
please help us accompagnés de messages
sur linkedin
whatsapp il est passé par tous les
moyens mais le juge a considéré qu'il
n'y avait pas de menace que les preuves
apportées à l'appui étaient fausses et
aujourd'hui voilà où on en est c'est la
deuxième fois qu'un ancien employé de
l'armée française est assassiné en
afghanistan en octobre 2018 kader
daoudzaï avait trouvé la mort dans un
attentat
après que sa demande de visa a été
refusé par la france il était interprète
magasinier ou chauffeurs et ils sont
aujourd'hui encore entre 60 et 80
auxiliaire à faire régulièrement l'objet
de menaces et attendre d'être sauvés par
leur ancien employeur
dont quelques heures des règles cheville
sera fixé sur son sort reconnu coupable
du meurtre de l'afro américain george
floyd l'ex-policier connaîtra le nombre
d'années qu'il passera derrière les
barreaux à washington en retour notre
correspondant thomas bonnet bonsoir
thomas une sentence qui est très attendu
et qui mobilise dans la rue
absolument le juge peter k il devrait
rendre son verdict dans une audience qui
va démarrer d'ici une trentaine de
minutes maintenant au tribunal de
minneapolis on rappelle que l'ancien
policier derek chauvine encourt une
peine allant de 12 à 40 ans de prison
les procureurs ont requis pour leur part
une peine de 30 ans d'emprisonnement
alors que l'avocat de la défense lui a
plaidé l'erreur de bonne foi il a
demandé à ce que la peine soit réduite à
la durée déjà purgé ce qui conduirait à
une remise en liberté de derek chauvine
un scénario qui semble assez peu
probable
beaucoup d'observateurs ici estime que
le l'ancien policier devrait écoper à
minima d'une peine de 30 ans de prison
alors ce vendredi pour ce qui concerne
le déroulé de l'audience les proches de
georges floyd auront la possibilité de
s'adresser au juge mais interdiction
pour eux d'échanger avec derek chauvine
l'accusé aura lui aussi la possibilité
de parler avec le juge mais on sait que
pendant l'intégralité de ce procès il a
pour le moment gardé le silence je
propose d'écouter l'avocat des proches
de john floyd sur ce qu'il attend de ce
verdict roseau phase active le bureau du
procureur général dirigé par keith
ellison a demandé une peine de 30 ans ce
qui selon certains calculs et le maximum
qu'il puisse obtenir deux juges pouvant
aller jusqu'à 40 ans
même si nous savons que la peine typique
pour une condamnation de meurtre au
second degré de 15 ans dans l'état du
minnesota
cependant il n'y a rien de typiquement
dans ce que derek chauvine a fait en
torturant georges floyd a marre when
they should be so we dance paix et nous
ne nous attendons pas à ce que ce soit
une peine spécifique
il faut que ce soit une veine ce qui
crée un nouveau précédent pour que les
policiers soient tenus responsables des
meurtres injustifiable de noirs en
amérique
ce procès s'est déroulé dans un contexte
médiatique et populaire évidemment très
particulier avec beaucoup de pression ce
qui fait dire à l'avocat de la défense
que les jurés qui auront rendu leur
verdict en 10 heures à peine ont pu être
influencer d'une manière ou d'une autre
par des éléments extérieurs il avait
fait la demande d'un nouveau procès une
demande qui a été rejetée c'est ce qu'on
a appris
il y à quelques instants en tout cas
beaucoup d'américains vont suivre en
direct l'annnonce de ce verdict
évidemment il ya tout un symbole on
dépasse complètement le cadre d'un
simple procès puisque la mort de georges
floyd en mai dernier avait provoqué
d'énormément de réactions beaucoup de
manifestations également et même à
l'endroit où je me trouve on est à
quelques pas de la maison blanche
et pour information la place où je me
trouve maintenant a été renommé l'an
dernier par la maire de washington la
black like the matters plaza c'est donc
vous l'aurez compris bien plus qu'un
verdict qui est attendu c'est un symbole
fort qui pourrait être adressées aux
revers tous les américains et verdict
attendu donc dans une trentaine de
minutes on retrouvera évidemment thomas
bonnin dans notre journal à de 21h à
tout à l'heure thomas
et c'est avec regret que le kremlin ans
dit avoir appris le rejet par l'union
européenne de l'idée d'un sommet entre
bruxelles et moscou
une semaine après la rencontre à genève
entre le président russe et son
homologue américain joe biden
angela merkel et emmanuel macron
souhaité organiser une rencontre avec
vladimir poutine pour traiter des sujets
d'intérêt majeur pour lieu mais au terme
d'un sommet européen de deux jours aucun
consensus n'a été trouvé à les pays
baltes la pologne la suède et les
pays-bas s'opposent à la proposition
franco-allemande pour relancer le
dialogue avec moscou paris réaffirme de
son côté la nécessité pour l'union
européenne de parler à haut niveau avec
la russie
nous sommes convenus de l'importance de
maintenir une approche unifiée à
l'instar des mesures adoptées de manière
solidaire au cours des derniers mois
mais à avoir également une approche
volontariste et planifiée et non pas de
céder en quelque sorte à la réaction
systématique aux provocations ou
agression et avec la chancelière nous
avons proposé justement de documenter
l'ensemble du champ de discussion sur
lesquels nous pouvons nous engager avec
la russie pour structurer un agenda qui
peut être un agenda de coopération et de
travail conjoint dans les prochains mois
et un agenda de clarification ou parfois
de désaccord mais celui ci doit être
structuré pensée voulue par les
européens il ya eu une longue discussion
sur l'opportunité d'une rencontre avec
le président poutine cette discussion
pour moi n'est pas de rang 1
nous nous rencontrons le président
poutine en tant que membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies en
permanence et par les sommets que nous
faisons par contre nous avons structuré
un agenda commun et je veux voir là un
progrès considérable depuis que la
france a engagé ce travail depuis le
mois d'août 2010 9 à la russie se dit
toujours disposer chat dialoguer avec
l'union européenne
la correspondance à moscou de verre à
gauche man vladimir poutine a été et
reste toujours intéressé par
l'établissement
relations de travail entre moscou et
bruxelles a déclaré le porte parole du
kremlin dmitri peskov
et là tout de même souligné que la
russie espérait que le pays européens
qui ont une approche plus équilibrée
continuerons à travailler pour
promouvoir le dialogue entre la russie
et l'union européenne je vous propose
d'écouter
nous le regrettons les liens vous savez
qu'en général le président poutine a été
et reste toujours intéressé par
l'établissement de relations de travail
entre moscou et bruxelles et sur le plan
conceptuel la position du président
poutine selon laquelle nous sommes prêts
à avancer dans cette direction dans la
mesure où nos homologues sont prêts à le
faire reste évidemment d'actualité
le vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères alexandre grouchko a quant à
lui déclaré que l'union européenne s'est
retrouvé otage d'une minorité agressive
à savoir les pays baltes et la pologne
il a également noté que pour dialoguer
il fallait être deux mais que l'union
européenne préférée monologuer écouter
l'union européenne s'est retrouvé otage
d'une minorité agressive qui mène le bal
est otage de décisions prises au
préalable
à l'issue du sommet du 24 juin plusieurs
dirigeants européens ont annoncé que les
conditions nécessaires à l'organisation
d'une rencontre souhaitée par la france
et par l'allemagne n'était pour
l'instant pas réunies et pour gilbert
casasus professeur d'études européennes
si la tentative franco allemande à
échouer
c'est tout même un signe fort de la
volonté des deux dirigeants européens de
voir l'union européenne jouer un vrai
rôle en politique étrangère écouter le
fait même que les deux grands pays de
l'union européenne à savoir la
république fédérale d'allemagne et la
france lance un tel message
c'est déjà un signe très fort c'est à
dire c'est aussi vouloir que l'union
européenne joue un rôle comme global
players en dire en anglais en politique
étrangère et ne pas laisser
à la russie aux états unis dans ce cas
là non mais à la chine
le monopole des relations
internationales la france par macro
l'allemagne par merkel voulaient tout
simplement déclaré nous sommes nous
l'union européenne
la principale puissance économique au
monde laissez-nous est aussi une des
très grandes puissances politiques
commencent israël rétabli l'obligation
de porter le masque en antérieures plus
de la moitié la population pourtant reçu
deux doses de vaccin anti qu'ovide mais
le pays fait face à la circulation
active du variant delta plus de 100
nouveaux cas de contamination sont
détectés chaque jour écoutez ces
quelques réactions
je me sens triste parce qu'il fait chaud
maintenant et nous devons le porter mais
dans notre côté c'est pour notre
sécurité
parce que le coronavirus revient et le
variant indien et plus agressifs que les
autres
le masque tout le temps à l'intérieur à
l'extérieur
je me sens en sécurité avec les masques
c'est mieux pour nous en tunisie la
reconnaissance de quatre couronnes un
virus inquiète l'état d'urgence est
prolongée d'un mois quatre gouvernorats
sont confinés et face au manque de
moyens matériels et humains le personnel
soignant à bout de souffle attendu des
solutions concrètes
bassam chebbi les amatrices se sont
rendus à kahone l'un des gouvernorats
les plus touchés face à l'afflux de
patients ces dernières semaines à
l'hôpital de kairouan c'est à même les
salles d'attentes que sont pris en
charge les malades du co lead
ici comme dans l'ensemble du gouvernorat
on manque de tout les carences en
matériel en oxygène en lits et même en
personnel rendre le quotidien des
soignants toujours plus ardue et
dangereux une situation critique que
dénonce le corps médical
nous sommes fatigués épuisés c'est une
réalité on ne supporte plus voir des
patients mourir sous nos yeux et être
dans l'incapacité de leur venir en aide
ou de leur fournir de l'oxygène
cette situation n'est plus possible il y
a même un de mes collègues médecins qui
s'est fait agresser à cause de ça mais
nous concrètement d'où est ce que l'on
peut lui apporter de l'oxygène
si nous avions à l'hôpital de l'oxygène
inexploité je comprendrais mais là on a
rien ici et on se fait agresser et ça ce
n'est pas normal
le problème c'est que rien n'est
disponible ici la seule chose que nous
avons nous l'avons déjà utilisé
l'arrivée des malades est trop
importante jour après jour le double
voire le triple de notre capacité
d'accueil
la solution c'est le gouvernement qui
doit la trouver pas le personnel
soignant
car tous les jours on on reçoit de plus
en plus certains même arrivent dans un
état critique et en charrette c'est à se
demander si nous sommes en 2021
dans ce gouvernorat le taux de
positivité okogie 19 n'a fait que
grimper ces derniers mois passant de 40
% en mai
plus de 65% pour le mois de juin alors
comment expliquer une telle
recrudescence des cas positifs dans
cette région pourtant épargné lors des
première et deuxième vague à l' agence
régionale de santé de kairouan malgré de
nombreuses mises en garde adressées au
ministère de la santé le docteur mohamed
drissi et son équipe sont à pied
d'oeuvre
objectif coordonner du mieux que
possible l'action du gouvernement et le
travail des personnels soignants sur le
terrain à laval samedi on a vu que la
situation dans une situation très grave
s'annonce mal et ça il serait ensuite
appelée rappeur le taux de taux de
vaccination des deuxièmes on a remarqué
au niveau de vie le nouveau les gens
respectent mal les valeurs de santé
il ya trop d'encombrés m'emmener au
niveau de la vie les agglomérations
privé ne s'arrête pas il se et pousse à
amman en a déduit de la situation elle
peut devenir les gars même son de cloche
du côté de la mairie de kairouan face au
nombre croissant de décès le maire de la
ville a été contraint de développer des
partenariats financiers avec des
associations et organisations privées
pour pallier le manque de budget
nécessaire à la gestion des inhumations
un coup dur pour cette région qui
commençait tout juste à sortir la tête
de l'eau après le confinement
généralisée de l'an dernier qui a
enfoncé en vaucluse et la ville de
carros dans la précarité le jitter
nos finances sont
ce sont des terroristes cette année
pratiquement tous nos tous nos projets
sont arrêtés pour faire
face à aux nouvelles dépenses de
protection de nos emplois et surtout
pour les innovations pasqua côté
animation nous sommes débordés il ya
beaucoup de demandes depuis et même
avant la pandémie de
de matériel de moyens humains ces autos
et de médicaments mais il n'y a pas de
deux réponses à ces six maintenant les
choses ont commencé à changer il ya une
réaction assez rapide surtout de la part
des militaires qui ont installé à un
hôpital de campagne
face au risque de l'apparition d'un
variant brésiliens ou indiens en tunisie
le gouvernement a annoncé que d'autres
gouvernorats pourrait être également
confinés dans les prochains jours
gibraltar assouplir la législation anti
avortement quelque 62% des électeurs se
sont prononcés en faveur d'une loi
autorisant les vg mais sous conditions
l'enclavé britannique posséder jusque là
l'une des législations les plus durs au
monde en la matière grasse d'ailleurs
ils sont 62% des électeurs à s'être
prononcé en faveur de l'assouplissement
de la loi sur l'avortement
dans les faits la loi autorise désormais
l'avortement lorsque la grossesse
présente des dangers pour la santé
mentale ou physique de la femme
notamment en cas de viol d'inceste ou
d'une déficience mortel pour le foetus
un référendum qui a été lancé à
l'initiative du gouvernement local okal
plus de 52 % des habitants ont voté un
soulagement pour les partisans du oui
qui se bat depuis plus de trois ans
oui aux droits de l'homme oui aux femmes
et aux jeunes filles
il veille à la confiance dans les
médecins et aux professionnels de la
santé
[Musique]
oui au choix où il ya la compassion et à
l'empathie oui à un système de santé et
aux soins
oui aux droits reproductifs oui à
l'autonomie corporelle des femmes et
louis à l'avortement à domicile sur est
légal du côté du gouvernement on compte
acté au plus vite cette évolution de
moeurs avec notamment un accompagnement
des femmes
le gouvernement va donc maintenant et
dans un délai de 28 jours faire débuter
la loi de 2019 sur l'amendement des
crimes mais nous le ferons également en
mettant en place des mécanismes de
conseil et de soutien aux femmes afin de
garantir que toute femme qui frappent à
la porte de l'autorité sanitaire de
gibraltar
estimant avoir besoin d'un avortement
aura le soutien dont elle a besoin
avant la loi l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse était interdite et passible
de la prison à vie si bien que la
plupart des femmes concernées devaient
se rendre en espagne ou au royaume uni
si ce référendum est un progrès majeur
il a fortement divisé la population dans
un pays habituellement unis dans ses
choix
we know nous savons nous sommes
conscients que certaines des doigts
concernant l'avortement doivent changer
comme la prison à vie et d'autres choses
comme ça mais cette loi est trop large
et trop les femmes ont le droit à la vie
privée et à l'intimité et elles ont
également le droit de ne pas être
soumises à un traitement inhumain et
dégradant
lorsqu'elles sont forcés de poursuivre
une grossesse contre leur gré cette
réforme sur l'avortement fait suite à
une décision de la cour européenne en
juin 2018 qui avait estimé que
l'interdiction volontaire de grossesse
en irlande d'une heure était contraire à
la convention européenne des droits de
l'homme dans toute l'europe l'avortement
est actuellement autorisé à l'exception
de la pologne la pratique est restreinte
et de malte qu'il interdit totalement à
gibraltar toute femme de l'enclas
britannique de 32 mille habitants pourra
désormais se faire avorter jusqu'à la
12e semaine
si elle estime qu elle ou son enfant
sont en danger était la fin de cette
édition prochain journal à 21,1 tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour assister
à une guerre dans l'est